Keep Calm let him grow oh I can't
yeah but you can enjoy she can do that
well I never even noticed that he really
did that until you Stirling I just
showed her that picture just so that's
given to us by a very nice artist gig
gave us that for free so thank you so
much I want to turn it into a t-shirt
which I probably will yeah so thank you
once again this is all your fault
that sounded funny this is a lemongrab
episode and it's I just got
uncomfortable kind of watching this
looks I really don't like that okay like
what this way like I know it's not
supposed to be like so it got its job
died do you know it's five at the same
time just like just like Oh like just
everything has a sad face and everything
is just like now look at you words tired
alright everything looks miserable in
that place I even you know like with the
nightosphere or whatever it's called
like you know that was at least some of
the weird crazy creatures like had a
happy face or self maybe everyone here
just looked miserable so they asked a
bubblegum for more candy even though
she's giving them more than enough so
Jake and Finn go to give them some candy
seeds and it turns out the two
lemongrabs have been pouring this sort
of miracle juice that bubblegum had to
bring light to all the candies and for
no other reason than them just doing it
if I'm right I mean they just really
loved the feeling of someone new coming
out and their new voices yeah I mean
even when they give them this answer
anything they are starving they are down
to nothing I mean frantically skin and
bones and well here's some candy seats
oh they put all together pour the juice
I had just puked and I could so so then
they tell the candy people are gonna go
to bubblegum to figure out how to fix
this and I know if it was the key
or the castle whatever but it turns out
it's just a live I guess they put the
cheese on it too and it just came alive
starts marching towards the kingdom and
they try to kill the heart but instead
get it going and it feels feelings and
decides it's gonna give itself to the
world and does exactly that
yeah the little lemon candies and then
bubblegum literally a racist from their
mind which i think was my favorite joke
that the writing on their brains and
she's so fair now they'll never want to
do that formula again and that's it
definitely out there uh like I said I
find this place really miserable but
it's I don't know that's like it's not
enjoyable miserable but for some reason
I don't mind it I'm sort of like oh okay
that's just I don't know it's just maybe
just didn't annoy me quite in the way
you know that it gets me angry about the
same time I'm just sore like well an
awful place it reminds this episode
specifically reminds me of a lychee
facade the music is no just which
episodes in general the music is a bit
off there's a lot of just creepy imagery
throughout the entire thing to the point
where Finn and Jake are actually getting
creeped out get their to hold hands when
they're going when you're going through
like the dungeon area and everything
they keep opening these doors and
they're like what is going on they're
just like getting more and more creeped
out until they finally opened this one
door and there's he's like no if I
remember if they were lungs that weren't
doing anything or were they lunch or
kidneys kidneys knees here little tiny
goes head peels baggage it's like no
perception or kicks open the greatest
chef in yeah I think that was my other
favorite but like that's kinda feel like
Ephram was like the whole atmosphere of
this one was just kind of creepy and
bizarre and off-putting every one of
these creatures that they created
so little time innocence was put into
them and so little care there just like
a bizarre combinations of anything and
everything and yeah I have a feeling
that like every single one is like
suffering deep down inside they're like
kill me now yeah looks like constant
separate from everybody I mean that's
like it you know you said it was creepy
answer like what we seen episode you
know yes sir the nice theory so we've
seen stuff that's creepy but it's fun
this was like creepy and just
uncomfortable
oh yeah but like I said it's it seemed
to work and I can't quite explain why
maybe there's just something about it
was still creative it was still it's
like a train wreck
you know it's like you don't want to
look at but you can't turn away you're
just like what's gonna happen next
what's the next weird disturbing thing
I'm gonna see next and the other thing I
really like from a service
cinematography point of view is when the
kingdom grows and finn is hanging on
that shot of them going up and him
holding on to Jay and they you see the
feet going down and when they're movie
it's like men you felt that you felt
like they were really hanging on there
and I thought that was very effective oh
yeah like I said just and how much you
felt it going up so yeah I D I liked it
um and yeah lemon grant still didn't
annoy me but this was the first time it
was like yes just uncomfortable I felt
here we watch it oh so yeah I guess but
I love Lemongrab I like it I love this
episode it's and I don't know why I
can't explain it
he's everything I should absolutely hate
but I can't I can't
and and I it was just well my favorite
part was the little guy with his face
peeling up as he was screaming did
something straight out of a horror movie
which is great yeah you know what's so
great about that guy that's right man
why did that work so well I realize it
felt like Jay closed the door just
before it got to the absolute worst
point it's like what you saw was really
bad really creepy and you know the
absolute worst was about to hit a gov No
and closes it I think that's why it
worked so well I like that they were in
the dungeon and they think that they're
saving because - when I first started
watching - I was kind of like huh these
things like overtook the kingdom oh my
gosh
like you know the lemongrabs did
something but it got out of control and
now they got a hideout in the dungeon to
be safe or something and and you know
when at first they're like oh close the
door close the door the door so what was
it the door
wait the door the door yes that one -
that was a good one and then you come to
find out it's like no they're making all
these that's what gets me it's like
they're making all these people from the
food they're supposed to be eating
they're starving themselves they're
starving everybody that they're making
because there's no food to feed
themselves much less the people and then
at the end were they're like we're gonna
go to the candy Candy Kingdom because
Finn and Jake are like Oh Princess
Bubblegum will totally save us and
they're like alright everybody we're
gonna go and I'm not gonna do that voice
anymore
you know we're gonna go we're gonna take
all the candy from the Candy Kingdom and
we're gonna make more people from the
candy and then we're gonna go with that
army if and then we're gonna eventually
like eat candy like the whole eating
thing they're starving to death and
we're still a little concerned we just
want to make sure we have enough candy
people before we go and actually eat
well it's just it serves a little bit
that obsession and I know it's silly but
you know it's that obsession everybody
most people have like one little thing
you obsess over you know whether it's
you're a gamer or whatever and it just
it was kind of interesting kind of neat
you know I know someone who specifically
who will be on the computer all day and
then it's like did you eat lunch oh I
forgot telomere him I'm talking about
people oh okay
honestly you know what when I'm watching
whatever stupid show I'm watching on TV
it's the same concept Jason's like how
many episodes have you watching like I
don't know five so you've been sitting
on the couch for six hours yeah it is
strange we think about cuz I think
you're right there's always like you
know not only is eating important but
people I think like to eat there are bad
things to eat but there is always
something that's like that is even
better than I think everybody has gotten
to at some point where it's like eating
this natural tendency to want to live
you know to keep you living later second
do you know this adventure type first
night but ya know cuz there's definitely
nights where it's like I just pushed
myself to the grinder with something I
kept working it's like I'll forget I
haven't eaten dinner or lunch or
something like that so it's not a good
habit get into by the way don't like it
I'll be like Duncan every no don't do
that but yeah I think there is always
someone's always come across something
that they feel is just more important
for the moment you know then eating see
I disagree though with that being what's
behind the lemongrabs I kiss where the
longest time Lemongrab was alone Peebles
is finally like Oh hold on I figured it
out I'm gonna give you another you you
know sentence you accidentally left the
formula behind which what I like is that
no I I think that she left the formula
behind they find this and they're like
oh my god we don't have to be alone we
can make more people like us more lemon
people because that's all Lemongrab
wanted Lemongrab just wanted people
around him he wanted someone to rule
over or whatever this gave him the prime
ability to do it the candy and the
formula
and on top of it it looks like that'll
never be fed like you know again sir
interesting one for maybe that no matter
how many of these people he makes that
hunger for not being a low and heavy
people around him will never be fed you
know it's like they just keeps wanting
to make more people until he doesn't
feel alone and it's like that's never
gonna happen no matter how many people
he has around him
well because initially for me one thing
that threw me off at the episode was
lemonjon the big one yeah like oh my god
how the hell did he make that and people
says it in the beginning she's like oh I
gave them enough candy for a lifetime
yeah and if you think about it a
lifetime's full of candy or whatever
would probably fill a gigantic being
like that and then he commits suicide to
save both kingdoms lemonjon is the man I
don't like lemons we should bring that
back I will say this if anyone like I
can see somebody coming along saying
what a horrible idea it was just so
annoying and obnoxious uncomfortable if
that's what you think it's like I'm not
gonna say like what are you mad I get it
I totally understand where you're coming
from uh and yeah I think there is just
something to how they do it that still I
get that episodes just like lemongrab
it's kind of like it's loud and annoying
and kind of obnoxious but it's like some
reason some reason I still enjoy it so
yeah I think it's like the little guy in
the room
they always with Lemongrab they always
bring him or the episodes focusing on
him right to that breaking point right
before you snap you're like oh oh it's
all
yeah maybe that's it and I love
Lemongrab Lemongrab was one of my
favorites probably because she's so
bizarre and strange and all of that
stuff but I see what that little guy in
a shirt doing I know when I think that's
that's for me what I like about it is
specifically because it's disturbing in
a way I just have a different
sensibility and you know for an episode
like that for me to go it's just I mean
really it surprised me so much but I
can't oh my god this is what it's like
to have zombies gum you oh oh that's
that that is what keep doing on demand
it's like your cat get away from me
anymore don't look at me you're watching
it